monday p-f-t-o-t
extra time to talk about all the things
we didn't get to or the things we just
feel like talking about a little bit
more chris sims mike florio here week
one in the books but for the monday
night doubleheader coming up later today
chris the story of the week last week
the story of the week this week and
probably the story of the season will be
antonio brown
he's gone from the raiders he'll
officially sign with the patriots today
yep
you were in new england as
well what we should do what did you even
do there what i mean what was your boy
that's it
actually what they put on me that's what
i felt like it was that's what i pretty
much said was your title i was offensive
quality control and then was in charge
of like some do some duties scouting
duties uh you know they kind of make you
do two for the price of one in new
england which was great experience
because you get to see all facets of
really how the organization works and i
think they want to see which way you're
going to be more inclined yeah coaching
side of the front office yes definitely
definitely right
neither well i think they were like we
can't modify how about waterboy can we
get this guy to do some water
okay but you were there for 18 months
right you know what it's like there yes
antonio brown is walking through that
door today to sign a contract right is
it going to work will he be there when
the playoffs roll around i do think it's
gonna work i think everybody just needs
to get used to it oh i'll say this at
the very least too it's not gonna blow
up in new england's face okay so there's
a there's a floor there that that i
wouldn't be scared about if you're a new
england fan or anybody like that because
as soon as they get an inkling of oh
this is not manageable they will just
say see you later as we saw last night
they don't need him to win football
games or for tom brady to throw for 300
yards but that's the most humbling place
in all of football because if you walk
in there as a star it doesn't matter if
you're randy boss or antonio brown
chadochu cinco you walk in and you go
whoa this regime doesn't need me and
that checks your ego at the door right
away plus it's just all business all the
time there in new england there's no
like oh hey oh yeah this is cool oh yeah
we're here and it's wednesday and we're
all laughing and having a good time
because we're playing football when you
walk in the door during the day in new
england it is work as soon as you cross
into that door and i do think it'll work
because of not only belichick but just
the culture around it and then having a
great leader like tom brady to help kind
of massage things along as well uh i i
don't see it being a bad thing remember
when reggie wayne went to new england
and exited quickly yeah it's not fun
yeah right it's and and we've heard that
from time to time it's not it's not for
everybody what's fun is winning the
super bowl what's fun is showing up at
robert kraft's house to get your next
ring that's where the fun is and for
antonio brown hey he's had his eight
months of fun or whatever you'll want to
call it and he's gonna have to conform
quickly and and he'll see we talked
during the show about
bill belichick ripping into tom brady in
front of guys like chad johnson randy
moss dante stallworth the message it
sends to them without him having to rip
them right he rips tom brady the
greatest of all time and it shows
everybody's in play everybody's in play
right the rules apply to everyone
but even with that knowledge
can antonio brown
follow the rules is he capable of
showing up on time is he capable of
paying attention in meetings is he
capable of being anyone other than a b
i i i don't know that is really the
million dollar question i i would hope
this at the very least
he realizes this is his last straw like
i would hope he realizes that if he
messes this up and most of the nfl if
they see whoa new england couldn't
handle them and couldn't adapt them to
their culture then he's going to be out
of football in general and business will
not be booming he will not be making
cash or anything like that so it is a
big question mark for a guy where you
know i do i worry about the guy a little
bit with some of the things that have
gone on on and off the field lately just
seems like he's lost lost his way to a
degree and um hopefully new england is
the kind of place that can refocus him
there but yeah that's the big question
of whether he can conform i'm gonna say
he can just because of the desperation
he needs the money and also the fact
that he's got a guy like tom brady
around him who's a really phenomenal
leader i'm just fascinated by how bill
belichick will try to implement this
will he try to
use the jedi mind trick where
antonio brown comes to conclusions on
his own that bill belichick wants him to
come to or will bill belichick have that
heart to heart saying antonio i don't
know how they do things in pittsburgh
and i don't care but we've won six super
bowls since 2001 and there's a reason
for that yeah and there's a way that
things are done here and if you do them
you'll be here and if you don't you
won't and it's that simple i know i
don't know if that'll work on it i don't
even know if he'll address it that way i
don't even know if he will i think he
almost would be one of those things
where it's like jedi mind trick like i'm
going to pay you no attention almost
right and there's 53 other guys here 52
other guys here other than you and i'm
going to treat you exactly the same way
and i just think he's going to learn
kind of just from being there and the
way things are said in meetings and then
when they have a team meeting and coach
belichick's in front of the team he's
going to realize that woo you know this
ain't kansas anymore this is not
pittsburgh or or oakland to where you
know they enable their stars a little
bit or placate to them but what happens
when he gets in trouble for something
and he doesn't like it yeah and he posts
something on my face as belichick would
call it and acts out right how do they
deal with him
i don't think there'll be any dealing
with him they will get rid of him they
will if he is not doing who makes him
understand that that he doesn't have
that that opportunity that he has one
chance michael who is going to sound so
weird i hope drew rosenhaus is making
him explain that to him at least that's
what he should be doing
it's hard for me to explain this but
this might sound weird but it's truly
like one of those things mike you feel
it when you walk in the building there
you just go
i was with three different nfl teams
i've been around football my whole life
my first day on the job there i was like
whoa this is like
the most uncomfortable like uptight like
whoa we're going to work and we're going
to grind it out and it was march and i
was like holy cow what's this place
going to be like in august you truly it
like just seeps out through the building
there and i
i really think that's going to be the
big thing more than anything he's just
going to realize it's no nonsense from
the get-go and nobody's going to like
have little special conversations with
him off in the corner bill might come up
to him during stretching you know before
pre-practice just to have a little
banter with him but he's not gonna be
like are you okay you okay oh you're my
guy i'm gonna get you the ball this week
well no he's not gonna do that
what john did none of that's gonna go on
he's just i really think it's almost
like osmosis once you get in that
building no hey it does make sense
shockingly
and and i really don't know what's going
to happen i want to see how the contract
is structured because even though we get
a 9 million dollar signing bonus if i'm
the patriots i defer the actual payment
as long as i can
right because it's easier to get it back
from him if you've never paid it too
right right right so you can minimize
the damage because you give them 9
million and see and i think part of this
is they are going to play to his ego to
a certain extent because
i first thought if the patriots going to
touch him it was going to be a minimum
salary deal with huge incentives you
have to be here you have to prove it you
know per game roster bonus you're going
to you're going to get paid as you go
right but they knew
he was upset because of what happened in
oakland they took away his guaranteed
money so what do they do they give them
guaranteed money right out of the gates
nine million signing bonus takes one
edge off of it right right and and you
know what if he has a big year he he
makes 15 million half of the 30 back and
he becomes a free agent next year and he
makes the other right and they'll
probably they'll probably give them the
other 15 next year if it works out this
year he's got the incentive to do it
part of me wants it to work part of me
wants it to be a disaster because it's a
great story as long as it's a disaster
it's a great story either i think either
way it's going to be a great story i
mean if he leads the league in receiving
in touchdowns we're all going to go this
is unbelievable story what a year my big
thing is this
when do you think antonio brown knew he
wanted out of oakland and wanted to make
a move to go to the new england patriots
because i don't think this was like oh i
got released let me call teams now and
figure out when do you think well i'm
just spitballing no
look it never worked in oakland for a
variety of reasons the whole thing with
the frozen feet and the helmet kept it
from ever really meshing right last
wednesday when he got that letter from
mike mayok that's when he was done with
the raiders now at some point between
wednesday and saturday
i'm do you think i have wednesday's
letter do you think it was it was
wednesday do you think it's wednesday's
letter that you didn't think it was like
i apologize to the team and then he
found out that his guarantees were
avoided no you think it was the letter
in itself wednesday's letter the moment
he put that thing on social media is
when he implemented his plan to get the
hell out of oakland and look everybody
knew that the patriots are interested in
him back in march but that the steelers
weren't going to trade him to anyone in
their division or the patriots so this
is the roundabout way this is the brett
favre to minnesota by way of the jets
without actually playing for the jets
that's what antonio brown pulled off
i've told you before i mean this guy he
at base level looks crazy but he also
might be crazy smart to pull some of
these things off because i i know i told
you this before and one of the reasons i
know in pittsburgh they had an inkling
that something was going to go down
because he he had told somebody there
who has told me you know i'm a
businessman first i love football but
i'm a businessman first so that tells
you he's very aware of that aspect of
the game and always trying to kind of
stay one ahead in the in the chess match
of business in the nfl we will find out
soon whether antonio brown is crazy like
a fox
or just crazy yeah we'll know we'll know
by halloween yes don't you think i would
think so yes all right uh we already
know that it's the same old jameis in
tampa bay after all that talk of of uh
bruce arians fixing jameis winston three
interceptions on
sunday against the 49ers two pick sixes
194 passing yards on 36 attempts not a
good day for the tampa bay offense which
had seven points given to it by the
49ers and a pick six from jimmy
garoppolo and you know i said all off
season this is either gonna go extremely
well or it's gonna be a disaster for the
buccaneers and i was rooting for
extremely well because i like bruce
arians but i have a feeling that by
halloween bruce arians is going to wish
that he had not come back to coach uh it
didn't look good certainly disappointing
you know i mean of course the tampa bay
buccaneers are the team that drafted me
i root for them uh i like jameis winston
i mean i want to root for him
in a lot of ways his good has been
really good but his bad is just it's so
bad it's just hard to
believe in him and yesterday listen i
understand interception is going to
happen that 49ers defense is is pretty
damn good but it's like the play like
the screen pass right they're backed up
nobody's there nobody's there he's not
open just throw it away at his feet but
instead he tries to like throw it over a
pile of people and thinks it's gonna
fall right down into his running backs
hand no
the running back got knocked into the
pile as well and then there's a kill
witherspoon just to grab it out of the
air and he runs for a touchdown it's
just too many bonehead plays like that
that uh is really discouraging for for
him the organization and everything
about it bruce aaron's kept it very
simple
when it comes to his instructions jameis
winston stopped giving the ball to the
other team yeah there was no effort in
there well not on tv i'm sure privately
but it's easier said than done you can't
change a guy it's baked in at this point
four years in the nfl it ain't changing
and i don't care what you do you're not
gonna take this guy and re-mold him into
something other than who he is whether
it's his fault or not whether it's bad
coaching in the past that's right bad
habits from it's gonna be very hard year
five in this day and age in the nfl to
turn a guy into something that he isn't
and the question becomes if this
continues against one game work in
progress but if this continues
where is he going to be next year i
don't know well he's going to be a
backup somewhere and then he's going to
be or he's going to be a middle uh yeah
what do they call it middle inning
middle reliever something like that
baseball player yeah middle reliever
that's what they call it adrian peterson
uh got a decent contract from washington
as running backs go in the off season
but now inactive week one against the
eagles they could have used them when
they were up 17 nothing chris you know
uh grind the ball run the clock etcetera
how surprised were you that he wasn't
even playing i was shocked i don't i
don't i didn't realize it until i got
here at nbc like you know 12 30
yesterday afternoon i just i would have
never imagined that was the case so
you're saying you didn't read
profootballtalk.com not yesterday
morning i did not i did not you know i
mean again i woke up i kind of tried to
enjoy the morning a little bit i was not
all over pro football talk but what was
the reasoning i mean that's that's what
i would like jay gruden said you know if
we're going to use i formation 50 times
a game then that's when we'll play him
but they you know that darius geist was
the the starter in the between the
tackles guy chris thompson the third
down guy and wendell smallwood who they
picked up recently the the guy who can
help out on special teams that's a
problem yeah on a running back depth
chart
if you're not one of the first two
then you got to play special teams and
uh he's not going to do that we thought
it was gonna be darius guys adrian
peterson one-two punch and that's just
not it yeah i mean i i was very
surprised for one
i mean you you bring up a good point
when you do have a lead like that uh he
is the kind of guy that you want to be a
workhorse type back but they believe in
darius guys i mean they thought darius
geiss was the best running back in the
draft two years ago so they're gonna try
to ride him but i just wonder if this
continues to happen you know will adrian
peterson become the squeaky wheel and
get his way out of there happen in new
orleans and he was actually playing
right right
28 yards rushing yesterday for
washington on 13 carries 2.2 yards per
attempt so something's got to change or
you're right and maybe they just squat
on them until there's an injury to
another running back somewhere because
we know that those running back injuries
are inevitable all right gotta go soon
losses that will resonate you know i
always say throw out week one
because you got 15 games left and
everything changes teams get better
teams get worse but but which of these
losses from yesterday leave a mark uh
well it's hard for me not to look at the
miami dolphins one really i mean because
there's losses and then there's
absolutely getting bludgeoned and
dominated to a point where you go oh wow
okay yeah i mean uh what was that final
score uh 59 to 10 59 to 10 you go oh wow
okay we lost the 3 10 and 10. but
they're going to go watch the film and
go we could have lost 72 to 10. we could
have lost 79 to 10. i mean that's how
bad that game was to me that's where
that was so bad so dominating so easy
for the ravens that i think it'll be a
number of weeks before the dolphins even
have any sense you know semblance of
self-confidence yeah i agree with you
completely and part of the aftermath of
that game you got guys on the team who
think that they're tanking and have told
their agents get us out of here so what
was the second one then who's it if you
went after that what's the next one well
i think losing at home
is always a bad way to start the season
for the browns i mean we've talked about
that that's a given that's going to
resonate how will freddie kitchens and
the browns handle that adversity i i
think that for the teams that had games
one that blew them right when it's a big
deal to get that win especially the
first one and in your division at home
against the division rival you're you're
the jets you're up 16 nothing and you
blow that one that that one's going to
hurt detroit
them too even though it was a tie i
still think it hurts up 24-6 right an
embarrassment there that you know as the
game went on
the cardinals made adjustments to the
lions that the lions couldn't match yeah
i know you're exactly right i mean
that's one yes where you talk about two
different teams arizona's gonna be happy
with the tide detroit's gonna be i can't
believe we let them come back and have a
thai football game i'll tell you another
loss that i think just looks at it would
scare me a little
is the atlanta falcons the way they lost
the way they looked in the preseason
especially up front on the offensive
line i would be a little worried there
altogether uh and then you know matt
ryan i know he'll play well it wasn't a
great day yesterday but i mean they
really kind of got dominated in all
three phases of the football game i mean
kirk cousins didn't have to throw the
football because they ran the ball well
their defense created turnovers and they
got a block punt early in the game that
gave him a short field and that was all
she broke and they turn it around next
sunday night against the philadelphia
eagles which will not be an easy no it
won't fall into an o and two hole and
you know if the saints come out strong
again the only good news for the falcons
the buccaneers lost the panthers lost
the saints could win tonight and be the
only unbeaten team in the division but
but at least the other two teams that
played also lost that's it if you're
looking for good news for the falcons
that's the extent of it and uh that's it
for pftot we'll be back tomorrow with
another edition of pft live chris sims
unbuttoned coming up later
help me understand what you're doing
right you can do a full film breakdown
for two games but yeah i usually on a
monday we'll do a recap of all the games
with like the two most interesting games
of the day i'll try to do like a a full
film breakdown as determined by twitter
really right exactly right we go to the
twit we go to twitter here i want to
know what the fans want to know about uh
and then wednesday i do more of a truly
deep dive around the nfl all film
included for all teams all right well
we'll look forward to that and thank you
and then later this week you're heading
to south bend oh baby i mean mexico all
i do is work work work work work yeah
but i am i'm pumped i mean going to
notre dame is always special being on
the field there i mean when you go to a
field and you hear that song on a weekly
basis and then you go man joe montana
tim brown you know new rockne paul
horning they were all on this field it's
it still gives me chills every time i go
well that's coming up this saturday we
got a full week of nfl content we'll be
back tomorrow with pfd live pfd p.m at
some point i don't know i don't know
what time i'm getting home today i may
crank one out today if not tomorrow
everybody have a great day we'll see you
on tuesday see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports